you've all seen Man of Steel by now
right cool let's talk spoilers and yeah
that is a spoiler warning for anyone
watching this video if you haven't seen
Man of Steel yet don't worry I made a
review with spoiler free review and I
made it just for you for the rest of you
let's talk some spoilers about this
movie first of all I'd like to thank
everyone who watched my Man of Steel
review and recognize that the rating I
would buy it on blu-ray is in fact a
positive rating and I'm advocating that
you see the movie because it's cool and
everyone heard that it's weird there's
really weird things logic and reason are
on your side friends okay so let's talk
about Manas Dale again with spoilers
this time so many steel starts out nice
on Krypton and like I said Krypton is
really cool it sets everything up Zod
stages his coup they do have this weird
system where you're like are those the
matrix babies all these babies are being
grown in eggs like in the matrix and I
guess Krypton they're like hey no sex
dude come on or they do have sex but
it's just for fun in which case yeah go
Krypton but kal-el is the first natural
birth in centuries he's like he's
special
and Zod actually kills jor-el I actually
like that you know he's screwed anyway
and about the half a day this plan is
gonna get torn apart like a ball of clay
it was kind of cool that Zod actually
got the knife in because now he's the
guy who killed jor-el jor-el would have
died anyway but now he's actually
especially a douchebag then they get
banished to the Phantom Zone which is
actually pretty convenient they get
banished there six hours later the
planet gets destroyed and then they get
free throw like a phantom zone I will
find it and blow away we're free how
long were we in there only that long we
can actually catch the newest episode of
Krypton's Got Talent right now Wow
didn't miss much except the whole planet
being destroyed then we get to earth and
kal-el is wandering the earth like Cain
and kung-fu or Jules Winnfield from
after Pulp Fiction he's trying to find
answers then you see through flashbacks
what he's gone through to lead him to
this point
I love the flashbacks in this movie
because it really shows how much he got
messed with as a kid and an adult even
as an adult he's in that bar that dude
grabs his girlfriend's ass and he's like
hey man he's in the nicest way possible
like he is super managed as he can he's
like just back off the guy splashes his
beer in his face pours it on his head
throws a can Adam you're like this is
remarkable restraint officially I'm not
Superman because I would have punched
through the guy's face although that was
cool to see kal-el take a little back
for himself the guy walks out and his
semi is just jack just like up on a
telephone pole with another thing
through it looks like a teepee it had
like a 3-part kabob
thing going you're like yeah I would
doubt you if you didn't do that good to
know you're still a person but he does
find out that in this glacier is a ship
it has his Superman suit and all the
answers he's looking for with like
twenty thousand year old ice around it
and it has a Superman suit in it alright
he needed the Superman suit and I am
questioning that thing when he got in
the ship that little droid that left
security droid that whipped him in the
arm and it hurt him you're Superman it
should just be like whip well that was
dumb well although he does crush it like
thirty seconds later so you know he's
stronger than it you can argue that well
it was made on Krypton and that's why
because it's Kryptonian technology and
is from his planet and he would be
weaker on his planet I would buy that if
he didn't on a few occasions in this
movie make holes in Kryptonian ships
either case doesn't matter he gets a
Superman suit now he's Superman but
General Zod comes to earth and he starts
acting like a dick and so now he has to
deal with that and I love that because
that's very Superman ish you know he's
floating there and he's like I want to
speak with Lois Lane don't play games
with me general and she's like why are
you surrendering to Zod he's like I'm
surrendering to mankind
there's a difference I was like oh
that's Superman I know and love Henry
Cavill on a few different levels I was
like you're awesome is Superman it was
big - the guy is enormous
after that oil tanker scene he comes
running up he has no shirt on you're
like dude put it away I don't want to
feel like less of a man because you're
awesome like that although this is just
a thought that crossed my mind that that
whole oil tanker scene install exploding
and he saves everyone on it would that
be kind of cool if in a Justice League
movie or an Aquaman movie of some sort
they established that Aquaman was behind
that like he's the one who destroyed
that oil tanker I think that'd be kind
of cool just a thought though just cross
my mind it's the thing that I thought
about heat vision was really cool - I
was wondering if he would have all of
his Superman powers he does and heat
vision is badass it's just such an
intense ray of heat and lasers like he's
shooting the Sun out of his eyes and you
see the varicose veins by his eyes and
it looks like there is a light bulb
inside his head and it's shining out his
eyes even when he's done he's like ah
yeah that hurt heat vision was so cool
was like Force Unleashed heat vision
among the flashbacks establishing
everything that's happened to make him
the man he is today we come to the
Jonathan Kent death scene and that was a
mixed bag thing for me in the usual
Superman Lord that I'm used to Jonathan
Kent has a heart attack and he just dies
in this one he's helping people get away
from a tornado and Clark can save him
but he tells me that ultimately tells
Clark to let the tornado kill him
because the world's not ready to see
what Clark and
these are two very different scenarios
made for two very different situations
he stood by and he watched him die and
he could have saved him but he didn't
because his dad just requested it and
it's a powerful thing it's very cool but
I've always liked the whole Jonathan
Kent dying of a simple heart attack bang
I've always liked the fact that of all
the things Superman can do he can't stop
everything he can't save everyone
life will trump even him a simple thing
like cholesterol can't do about it
unless he wants to advocate Cheerios on
do you want to be on Cheerios boxes then
he can probably do something about
cholesterol I was like how something so
simple can make even Superman feel so
small that's almost a question like what
do you prefer about the pock Kent
getting taken out with a tornado or
going out like curly from city slickers
let me come to the action and guys to be
clear I liked the action in this movie
it was badass I'll get to more of what I
meant about the maybe they could have
had a little less action later on in the
video throwing on Smallville is my
favorite one he just tackles dog he
starts just wailing away on him they go
through the gas station things are
exploding I'm like okay
it's happening I like seeing these
action scenes because Superman's never
really been able to show us everything
he can do on the big screen in a way
that's done really well either the
movies were made so long ago they didn't
have the tech for it or when they did
have the tech for it they made him lift
an island into space but no this
Throwdown is so cool cuz like the bad
guys are doing dual techs like Chrono
Trigger style throwing Superman someone
clothesline um check his bad ass by the
way I was thinking to myself I was like
why isn't sod standing out in my mind as
much as I think he should because this
chick is the villain that stole the show
she did everything I mean Zod had the
motivation behind it but this is the
chick first of all she has the hottest
eyes ever this is not a bad thing these
are positives but she's like hitting
dudes but she's doing really fast she's
not flying but I've always thought to
myself if these super people these
Kryptonians can move really fast why
don't they always move fast when they
hit people sure enough she's like she's
/ she's gonna jump onto a plane or capes
all blowing you're like yeah you're
getting it done man this chick is in it
to win it she was one vicious and
I loved her she's a badass then a train
is flying at kal-el you're like cheese
sands odds going to terraform earth into
Krypton essentially that worlds maker
thing was bad as all the gravity it's
all like boom
this gravity is just crushing everything
it's a circle of gravity's going out
with that's a ballsy move by the end of
this movie you're like metropolis really
got screwed it looks like nuclear
holocaust metropolis which is cool those
are high stakes you're like I will yeah
our world ending is as high as it gets
for us do you guys see that lexcorp's
sign there was there was a gas truck
that was thrown at Superman it said Lex
Corp on the side I don't know Easter Egg
it was cool but when kal-el goes to the
Indian Ocean to take out that other
thing that other side of the world maker
they establish that getting closer to
this thing might weaken him because it's
ultimately creating Krypton and we've
already seen that Krypton's atmosphere
makes them vomit blood and get a bloody
nose and pass out so what do they do in
this scene is this ship gross hentai
tentacles and it starts swatting at them
I've seen this movie a couple times at
this point both times I was like why
tentacles it looks like at that point in
the movie this is really the particular
time where I was like I could have done
without that get enough going on before
this scene they had a lot of action
you're gonna have more action to come it
looks like they're just throwing it on
there for the sake of entertaining us if
they took out the tentacles and had some
other reason for it being difficult for
him to complete his task I'd be kind of
cool you have this action sequence going
on over here the people in the plane
they're trying to fight the Kryptonian
chick and again you have a Throwdown
with Zod that's going to happen later on
in the movie so you don't need Superman
to really fight anything it'd be cool to
have a situation where he feels like he
can't complete his task and he has to
really dig deep and muster everything he
has to do it which they kind of do in
the movie in the sense that he's in the
beam and it's really hard for him to
stand up because of all the gravity and
he doesn't he flies up and blows the
thing away
but if getting closer to this thing is
gonna make him all sick and vomit it'd
be really cool to have a moment like
Metal Gear Solid 4 you know when snakes
crawling through the microwave hallway
and you feel like he's just dying all
the really sad music starts kicking on
you know and all the ambient noise goes
down he's just crawling kal-el starts
puking blood and he's getting a bloody
nose bloody ear maybe a hemorrhaging is
never good and him standing up is taking
all the strength he can muster and maybe
you can hear a voiceover of Jonathan
Kent talking about he was sent here for
a reason whatever he decides to be good
or bad he's gonna change the world then
he flies up and nails that thing you're
like yeah triumphs no need for tentacles
just there wasn't almost like that I was
talking about my review where I said
less action might have been more I'm not
saying that don't like action and action
movies for some odd reason when I said
that people heard I do
like action and comic book movies
whereas my Superman Returns blu-ray they
did it perfectly I don't know why is a
weird thing but some people heard that
the action in this movie is badass but
there are a couple of situations in the
movie where I was like if you held back
on that being an action sequence and
replaced it with something that I don't
know hit you here you might have a
better balanced movie that's all I'm
saying and you would still have easily
the most action-packed Superman movie
that does exist anyhow all the hentai
tentacle is in that situation that's all
done the other elias koteas crashed his
plane into the ship and L went back to
the Phantom Zone except Zod of course
and those odd and kal-el get into a
fight they get to a big old scrap and
he's all running up the side of
buildings like he's a bulldog kal-el is
flying at him and they're flying through
buildings and a lot of people are
probably dying and then sods like you
know what I'm a military leader I adapt
easily now we can fly and he can control
his powers I love how in Zod's helmet
breaks and he's looking around and he
sees the x-ray vision and he can hear
everything it really freaks him out and
he has to adapt to it he doesn't
initially I like the fact this movie
made it to where it takes them more than
five minutes to adapt to the x-ray
vision heat vision hearing everything it
takes him a day but this is the thing
where people are like no that wouldn't
happen like that and other people like
me are like that was awesome and it's
when kal-el takes out Zod Zod's using
his heat vision he's gonna fry this
family and ultimately kal-el has to
break his neck for it I've seen some
comments are like no Superman would
never kill a person first of all a lot
of these comic-book heroes who don't
kill people have been put in the
situation where they have to kill
somebody I mean shoot you look at Batman
people say he never killed me one in the
Dark Knight trilogy
did he not he did push Harvey Dent over
that precipice and he fell and snapped
his neck Batman did that
Harvey Dent didn't accidentally slip off
the thing Batman killed Harvey Dent but
it's all about how they executed it and
handled it I mean Zod has put Superman
in a situation where he's like you're
either gonna have to kill me or I'm
going to kill that innocent family and
kal-el has him in a headlock and he's
like dog don't do it stop he's pleading
with the guy to not do it he's giving
him every opportunity to stop this and
back down Zod's like never
so kal-el just snaps his neck he had to
the situation was either Zod dies or
that family dies even after it happened
it's not like he snaps his neck and
pissed on his face and he's like good he
stopped he paused and he just like
yelled and rage is yelled in pain that
that is this handled very well I would
argue if kal-el didn't break Zod's neck
to save that family I'd be like you
lack the conviction to do what's
necessary to save people I do not have
my trust in you where's Magog well
Superman has been punching Zod through
buildings I'm sure people have died from
that don't care stuff no one cares the
moment he breaks a maniacs neck though
that's the line the Lois and Clark
romance of the Lois & kal-el romance
rather I felt worked for this movie I
never felt like they should fall in love
in this movie I felt like this should be
an introduction that's more or less what
it was yeah they shared a kiss but
honestly who wouldn't in these
circumstances look at it through kal-el
his point of view this is a chick he's
connected with on a level he's never
connected with before she knows who he
is and is still interested in him his
last girlfriend we see from the
flashbacks was still dating the facade
and from her point of view it's very
simple the dude looks like that and he
saved the world and is indestructible
the fact that she didn't sit on his face
in front of the entire US Army that's
remarkable restraint on her part I
thought it was an interesting and ballsy
call you had a very cool call he shows
up at the Daily Planet as Clark Kent and
she's like I know exactly who that is I
think that works because let's face it
honestly I have never ever ever in my
life bought the fact that this chick
he'd have a crush on Superman work with
him and not know that Clark Kent is him
now never bought that in my life so I
like the fact that they're like yeah
that's unrealistic so we're gonna do it
like this as for where they can take the
sequels I don't know where they're gonna
take him Lex Luthor's tough to do
because you're not gonna have a throw
down like this with Lex Luthor unless he
has his Lex Luthor suit I guess you
could do that I would like to see in the
next one maybe there are some people
from the DoD who are not convinced that
kal-el is fighting for us Amy they
contract through another guy in another
company called LexCorp to create a
weapon or something to fight Superman
maybe it's based off of an artificial
intelligence an AI that they found in
that ship that Superman destroyed it
calls itself Brainiac and Lex Luthor and
the government and Brainiac all work
together until Brainiac just kind of
doesn't I would like to see Brainiac in
a movie they have yet to bring Brainiac
to a movie I don't know but like I said
I'm interested to see where they're
gonna go with this franchise Man of
Steel was a cool movie I did feel it's
imperfect but it's still great so Man of
Steel have you seen it what did you
think of it was it everything you hoped
it would be did you like it but we're a
little disappointed or did you just
flat-out not like it entirely
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you